I started to realize that I understood
things better than most players and play
with it wasn't like I had to be an ideal
but I just knew I had really good game
sense but not only tactically brawl so
much the team blow it get leaders
frakking like this guy Wow so
implementing a really deep hockey style
to the game
[Applause]
I'd say Cleve Hollis is probably the
best team in the world right now
that really informed and I think has a
good idea of how they should play and
how their system works yes I'm calling
the best in-game leader on the planet
I mean he's putting up superstar numbers
so it was a it was another thing I don't
know what happened in my career but I
knew that I had to get back to the top
what I knew that at some point I'm gonna
get the chance to be like the best thing
in the world
[Music]
Lucas egg home Ross endure was born on
June 7th 1995 he grew up in the neuro
section of Copenhagen Denmark the
eclectic multicultural neighborhood was
his childhood backdrop as he developed a
passion for competitive soccer
he played with several youngsters who
would go on to become major professional
players like ondrea's christensen but
when he was around 13 years old clave
began to experience symptoms of
osgood-schlatters disease a form of
severe knee pain that can happen to
growing adolescents training and
practice became very difficult by age 14
he'd been forced to find another
competitive Avenue thankfully he had
already found counter-strike and glaive
made a seamless transition to that world
instead my first trauma strike memory is
definitely from when I I went to a club
I'm not sure what it's called like it
was in my spare time after school I went
with my friends there and I remember
everybody played counter-strike together
it was like you could you could book one
hour from to use the computer and then
you could play with your friends and I
think I did that like almost every day I
played one hour and then I got my mom to
buy the game for me talking with one of
his friends who just happened to use the
handle device Lucas asked for a cool
alias he could use when we're device was
14 years old we were pretty good friends
and yeah I thought that device had a
really cool nickname and I asked him -
don't you have like a really cool one
for me and then he came up with clave
and I'ma like there's a sake really yeah
the name clave was born and he threw
himself into CS playing and watching the
game as much as possible ravenously
trying to learn its intricacies by
following and watching names like forest
get right Karn and Sonic while Glee
found a new competitive outlet it was
also sometimes an emotional one his
father Jacob the school teacher was
diagnosed with cancer in 2010 when
glaive was 15 and while he visited his
father in the hospital as often as he
could bear he sometimes felt like CS was
a safe haven for him
thankfully for glaive it was a project
that his father supported he could see
that it meant a lot to his teenage son
and he believed in his potential and
though he passed away in 2012 before
glaives peak was even in sight Jakob
Ross endure was proven right leaves
early competitive experience was in CS
source and it was a formative time in
terms of his end game leading style
he played on several rosters like reason
gaming Epsilon eSports and TT dragons
alongside fellow Dane Nicolai hundun
Peterson an IG l who believe credits
with much of his style the way he was
thinking about the games I played with
so the way they did things in the to
devise their own way to approach in game
leadership that emphasized map control
and mid-round calls with solid defaults
to fall back on picked up the second
joke with a third sandwich buy a kill
from eronel but they have a four versus
one right now so we'll go fine reckful
we know we won't find him in time and
the screams are starting to get louder
from the crowd everything was was good
and the weirdly was mid back calling
together with me was just like really
really really nice to play around and it
was it was fun to create this to go
blade would also fall back on his
fragging ability which he kept sharp
throughout his career the posting plan
but flame gets it for late back hold on
darling complain Kevin's damage Awards
that website if there were two versus
two big round here so let's go pick some
another one it's 1 vs. 1 and those
skills allowed him to play well on other
teams with different leaders while also
learning from them usually they don't
have the same impact the same frags I
should say so yeah that's that's really
tough so that's why I have always been
focusing a lot about my aim and not only
about the game says because if you want
to reach the top you got a you gotta
have their name but the release of csgo
was about to shake things up not only
for glaive but the entire danish scene i
think we had some identities problems in
the beginning of cisco like
we had to gather the the two seats from
one point six account of soy sauce it
was like an I think it was really really
hard to create the best things team out
of it but after a year of bouncing
around inside the Danish roster churn
bleh found a team that was able to
challenge some of the new scenes
frontrunners via Nexus roster that
became Western wolves HP though but
they're not gonna buy ok this is over
Wow Western wolves six teams of two it's
gonna be if the client does not clutch
this oh and there it is Wow he well
played ladies and gentlemen we are
writing history here Dreamhack summer
2013 second team to ever beat and I be
on land we'll go to Western wolves but
why max Glade with 25 flags
but as 2013 war on the Western wolves
roster once ranked third in the world
began to slip eventually glaive left
citing school concerns but couldn't stay
away from the game for long he played
with a variety of Nordic rosters until
he landed on Copenhagen wolves in mid
2014 though that talented squad looked
like they had potential they couldn't
break through and talk to your events
and now Kerrigan is in a one on two that
bomb is already down and retaking this
is going to be damn near impossible mana
Thomas world making sure he only has one
entrance but he's gonna be charging
through it he goes down suits with a
kill and then he survived copenhagen
wolves 1917 they make it to the playoffs
in late 2014 the situation on copenhagen
wolves came to a head at the gaming DK
tournament won a personal situation
between glaive and nikolai nico Jensen
boiled over and played threatened to not
play in the team's finals match blade
was slapped with a six-month ban from
GDK events and though these tournaments
were mostly for up-and-coming nordic
teams that was exactly the sort of event
the roster needed to play between
attempts to qualify for bigger
tournaments it wasn't long before the
copenhagen wolves kicked him but even as
he was on his way out the team's press
release called him a great player and
probably one of the most interesting
minds in counter-strike but after his
rough end to 2014 Fink's can
continued to get worse in 2015 Glade
began to question if this was even the
right path for him as teams like
Dignitas TSM and a new Copenhagen wolves
roster formed he was left out and so
glaive toiled in near obscurity he
played in a variety of smaller events at
qualifiers during the first half of the
year but basically dropped off the map
after May but while he debated an escape
a former teammate I always called him
[Music]
took his team again with him but in the
meantime a new Danish Power had risen
Team solomid was now clearly one of the
top teams in the world managing a top 4
finish at a major and routinely winning
matches against the Swedish powerhouse
fnatic the boys gonna get blinded here
in Kerrigan well done TSM their first
victory and in this company what a way
to do it so when belief returned to
counter-strike in 2015 and joined
copenhagen wolves again in early 2016
he had one ultimate goal to join the
team that was now called Astros but
there yeah back in 2015 my life wasn't
the same as this now I wasn't playing it
as rallies at one of the best teams I
was playing for some kind of unknown
teams so it was a it was another thing I
don't know what happened in my career
but and I knew that I had to get back to
the top because I had been to the top
before the
took like three months break I fell a
bit down I have to climb my way back up
but he was determined to show that he
could still compete even playing through
a collapsed lung at assembly winter 2016
I had three collapsed lungs and like one
year one and a half year and the third I
had it was in February right before the
semi-final at the event in Finland I had
to get the operation down there I didn't
in game leave back then because I didn't
want to but I knew that at some point
there's going to happen something then
I'm gonna get the chance to be like the
best engineer in the world though he may
not have known it believes determination
was about to pay off
and his fragging may have been what gave
him the opportunity oh okay that's
awkward
don't [ __ ] squat it out and okay they
trade right off but freakazoid now two
kills under his belt six each beat
oh no get shut down and astralis needed
a replacement for ESL one cologne 2016
because their newest edition key RB had
played the qualifiers with a different
team the results given the circumstances
were good
they not only integrated glaive into
their system but they managed to finish
top eight retaining their legend status
and to all of that despite the fact that
Dupree developed appendicitis partway
through the tournament and astralis were
forced to play with their coach sonic
Carrigan's desperate to find one of the
smoke instead it's MSL found by zipping
sin the hero play thank lei will close
it let's draw lists to status players to
standing players keep their legendary
status
again what was Dignitas is best chance
that is heartbreaking for Dignitas but
my goddess trawl is societally if it has
to be glaives profile had only risen
since cologne but now he finally had his
chance to forge a new legacy with the
straw 'less at the top of his Regency
the team wanted to move away from
Kerrigan's looser style so graves fit
well a more tactical approach with
reliable default for razor sharp
mid-round adaptations I can be a really
good early round in-game leader where I
tell them in the beginning of the round
what are we going to do this round but I
think what I'm best at and what I have
always been best at is that if something
we doesn't expect happens then I'm
really fast at winning game at what are
we going to do now with only three
months until the next major the team put
in work astralis had not yet earned a
major championship could glaive be the
missing piece of the puzzle and could
the high power to stralla be the team
glaive needed to cement his place in CS
history almost immediately it seemed
like the answer was yes after a shaky
group stage Astralis were crowned major
champions at the elite major atlanta
with bracket wins over na'vi and fnatic
and a nail-biting series against virtus
Pro he goes down with the max and he can
make it happen finally Pasha coming in
with a reef right but he's down the bomb
has been picked up by Dupree
cranial takes one in times of that and
estrada that we the first major
championship 16
Oh
[Music]
kids s-tronic
[Applause]
a new look astrologers Iliad throughout
2017 a top-floor finish at pgl major
Krakow and various other events that
year made them solidly one of the
world's best teams but while 2017
started hi 2018 started with a wake-up
call with the Vice returning from
medical leave the team suffered a
devastating group stage exit at the
Boston major both of them with eyes on a
grand Amancio they spotted him they
definitely knew one there's the kills
16-6 Estrada's center people cloud9 who
continue into the tournament they're
gonna play later date unfortunately
enters for astrologer your danes they're
eliminated that ends the playoff streak
of a couple big players and it ends no
Danish teams into the playoffs in Boston
not this time
even worse was key Arby's departure in
February for new Danish organization the
north move they forced a strong's to
scramble for a new fifth when I got the
news one RBI was still on vacation I was
obviously shocked I didn't know what to
say right we I thought that I feel still
feel like we're good friends but in all
honesty I we would just have appreciated
a conversation about it because also
still at the moment we really don't know
why it's just yeah it's just sad to feel
betrayed in some way but just as glaives
addition was both urgent and incredibly
effective Astralis added magic and well
the rest is history
megistias one more weapon in glades
Arsenal giving astralis yet another
explosive talent that could take over
games but astralis under glaives
leadership did much more they took over
the entire game their second major in
London
hey yo he's quite a fountain gotta stay
alive now thoughts another fountain the
twist
going for the whole glaive says no
holding it now and there is it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the million dollar Intel Grand Slam on
the retake that's absolutely massive the
DTS as well and is played getting it
done he's an astrologer so close to this
point
security can you believe it and that's
why they consider the world's best right
now
a third major in katowice their second
in a row Bri that's gonna claim the
first kill on this matchup they've all
tied with two one tops and that's the
bomb going down with it easily have to
pick up the third and walk in the smoke
flavor he'll only punish one but it's
just aerial fine
[Applause]
majors back-to-back on straw again
[Applause]
and a fourth in Berlin three in a row an
unthinkable achievement flame through
the smoke finding a trend in a bond was
born
[Applause]
they have just reestablished dominance
big
and for glaive specifically an NVP nod
at IEM beijing 2019 is first-ever and a
rare honor for an i GL and all lofts
gonna pursue with confidence into the
next kill but clave has the rifle and is
ready to free you can see many has Aston
head right fine and but through the
dories tank Dupree go on believe weakens
he knows as well that it's likely he'll
go towards the knows that he's done damn
meeting with him in mid 2020 glaive
announced he would be taking a
three-month break from the game to deal
with burnout unlike his previous break
this one will be to ensure he could stay
at the top
and unlike assembly winter 2016 he's not
just going to play through it glaive
didn't build the astrologer but his
unique approach and individual ability
have honed it into what is undeniably
the greatest counter-strike team ever
and he's kept them there he stands apart
from all other IG ELLs in the game's
history and though he did all this he
spent much of his career a long way from
the spotlight but like others along the
way he believed in his own ability and
he too was proven right no people said
that we could win on home soil and I
think all of the team knew that it
wasn't true and I figured all of the
Danish fans in the crowd they knew that
it wasn't true they knew that we could
do it they believed in us all the way
but the crowd helped us a lot thank you
very much
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]